Hey y'all I want to give a big thank you to TikTok for sponsoring this episode.
TikTok is joining us in celebrating Asian Pacific American Heritage Month,
and we're showcasing the amazing #AAPI family and the amazing creators and talent they have.
May is a special month for us because we ready to just celebrate the
beautiful, incredible creators that are part of the Asian-Pacific American community.
So make sure you check them out in the link below with the hashtag #aapifamily.
Also, Jubilee we've just launched our own TikTok. So make sure you check us out there, too.
Without further ado, enjoy odd man out.
- Can you guys do the renegade?
- Yes!
- I don't--I don't dance. I don't dance.
- I don't dance either, but I can do that.
- If you are watching this you should know that like, this took me hours to learn
- To me the great hope is that now these little
8-millimeter video recorders and stuff that come around some --
just people who normally wouldn't make movies are gonna be making them and you know,
for once, the so called professionalism about movies will be destroyed forever
(Old man) What?
[High pitched laughing]
(Trevor) - I am a tiktoker
(Adam) - I am a tiktoker
(Melody) - I am a tiktoker
(Angel) - I am a tiktoker
(Eva) - I am a tiktoker
(Rahan) - I am a tiktoker
(Bryan) - I am a tiktoker
(Chinenye) - I am a tiktoker
(Alexus) - I am a tiktoker
(Ana) - I am a tiktoker
- Alright
What's up? How you guys doing?
- Hey guys!
- So I think we should start with uh, how big or you know-
Just number of followers and then what kind of content we create like the niche (neesh?)
- Niche? Okay.
- Generally with these things is that the first person to kind of grasp their attention and to you know,
Kind of lead the conversation is the one that kind of gets to stay on there as long as they can.
On my screen,
We have melody first. So melody you want to start
- Sure
Adam was the first one to talk and he was the one trying to take control of the situation a little bit
I've produced content more on the basis of education
I have 58.7 followers --
thousand followers --  58 thousand
- You guys may need to go faster.
- Oh crap. Alright, alright. For me, for me
Um, I do comedy on Tik-Tok and I'm currently at 2.1 million.
- That's the same thing, I feel
- 35,000 over here
(talking over each other)
- It was just a hectic first minute.
- When I get nervous. I start talking a lot
So I got aggressive.
My niche is just doing weird things that make 10 year olds laugh
- I do makeup--I do makeup by the way just, the highlight. I'm just letting you know.
- Okay, go ahead and send me who you think the moles are.
You'll vote for two people
- Cheyenne I was rooting for you.
- Alexus like really didn't get a chance to talk to the group, so I felt kind of bad.
- In my head I'm like, "Oh maybe if I spoke for like three seconds less!"
- Everyone else is talking a lot more.
- I don't know who did it,
so I'm kind of hurt but.
- Okay, guys, I have some questions. Let's do it?
My strategy for the game was to basically be the police be the investigator.
- When she started asking a lot of questions, that's when I got really suspicious.
- Who has more followers, Charlie or Addison?
- When people gave the answer first a lot of people followed.
- If you guys are on TikTok then you know the song [gliched], so I'm not gonna sing the whole thing.
But I'mma start the song, do you guys know the song?
- I ha-- uh
- Maybe not lyrics, but like
- Ok then, wha--
- Let's do a more common one
Wait guys, what's the national anthem?
Who knows this one?
- Please rise for our national anthem
*Open up the safe, bitches got a lot to say.* (TikTok anthem)
- So the mole started researching TikTok,
you know recently right
so can you guys name some trends for maybe four months ago?
- The Furry Versus Gamer trend, there was the Ego trend.
- Melody, I thought just seemed very eager to prove that she was a TikToker.
Also me too, like I did the same thing.
You've earned my respect now, Melody.
- Aww! Thank you!
- Can you guys do the Renegade?
- Yes!
- I don't- I don't dance
- Don't dance either.
- Who created the original Renegade?
- Oh, her name starts with a "J," she is so cute.
I was paying attention to all the trends people knew.
- She did it for the NBA and she did it for Ellen.
- Yeah, Michelle Obama posted it and I was like--
- But is Ellen like, that cool though?
- NO!
- Who's--who's Dixie's boyfriend?
- That really attractive guy.
- And you're going to have to select two more people.
- So sorry, Rahan
- Her lighting setup was just a little too "YouTube"
- Her makeup is so good.
- Maybe Jubilee was trying to trick us by using YouTubers.
- Maybe I was intimidating or because I was harsh on the questions.
- Her makeup
Like, it's bomb.
- Alright and then we have a two-way tie between
Trevor
and Anna.
Her name is Ana not Anna. My bad.
I'm going to uh,
Set the timer for one minute and we're going to have a tictok move dance-off.
(*Cannibal by KE$HA backtrack plays* they try karaoke)
- Okay question, on the part where it says pitter-patter
what sound effect appears in the actual sound
- Boom boom
- Isn't it like
- Trevor's real.
- I promise, guys, I make TikToks
- What does this mean?
- Oh, this is I'm nervous, I'm shy.
Addison posts this a lot recently with her little brother.
I--I promise guys, come on.
- Okay.
- I'm sorry
- (sigh) You know like the worst part was the fact that like
Trevor also said he didn't know how to dance
so it kind of made me think like,
"Okay, maybe I'm not gonna get eliminated."
I just got a little suspicious for being a little bit out of the norm, I guess.
Bye.
How do I get off?
- The bottom button, the bottom-right.
- Raise your hand if you think that the mole is still in the game
and you want to continue
- Who is everybody's like, favorite creator on TikTok?
- Abby Roberts hands down. Best makeup artist.
- Oh my gosh, I love her makeup videos and her sister is so cute, too.
- Who remembers Varli?
(all) - Oooh
- She's iconic!
- "Don't fear Varli's here," right?
- Oh, man!
- Has anyone like, uh had any like,
encounters with other TikTokers before?
- So my friend she makes TikToks,
she's the one who does (sings) "My loneliness."
- Oh my gosh
- No way!
- Do you guys know somebody named um,
ARBACN? Uh, her real name is Aisha.
She's a really funny Filipino girl. She does--
- Oh!
- I love her!
- Is it--Is it the girl with scoliosis?
- She has scoliosis!
If you're watching this? Girl, hi--I love you, hit me up.
- I got a question the creators know okay?
When you post a video,
generally, how is the video scored?
- I was just--I was suspicious, you know?
I wasn't getting to TikToker vibes.
Hey Eva?
- Mhm?
- How many followers do you need to go live?
- Oh, I'm pretty sure it's 10k.
- Uh oh!
- I'm not there, I haven't hit it yet, so I'm not--
Because I'm at 8,400
so I'm not able to go live yet.
- Okay, okay.
- Aren't you--I'm, I'm so sorry, I think it's 1,000.
- Yeah, that's why I asked.
- It's 1,000.
- Okay, I don't know how to go on live anyway, so.
- Oh, you just swipe left.
It's so easy, it's like, I could pull it off.
- All right, well, thank you guys!
- Bye Eva.
- I'll be sure to go on live now.
I didn't know how many followers you have to have to go on live on TikTok.
It's a little embarrassing I didn't know but, it's okay.
- Raise your hand
if you think the mole is still in the game
- The background behind me, if it changes red,
that means the mole is still in the game.
If it changes green,
it means you got the mole.
- What?
- Let's see if Adam is a good liar or not
- What? Why me?
- I don't think so, but you're the only person I was like--
- No.
- What?
- He's either a great liar
or I look like a dipshit right now.
(Spongebob Narrator) - A few minutes later
- And on the count of three can the moles
turn their cameras on to reveal themselves.
One,
two,
three.
(overlapping gasps and exclamations)
- Angel.
- I'm so sorry!
- Everybody turn your cameras on.
- Oh, man!
- You got me!
- Definitely did not expect Angel to be the mole
because he just seemed like he knew so much about TikTok
- You bamboozled all of us! What the heck?
- I just have to say, Angel is no longer an angel in my eyes.
- He played the game so well,
I never suspected him for a second.
His makeup was incredible.
- I was keeping a list
of the suspicious people
I put you as not--least suspicious.
- Honestly, I've never had so much anxiety in my life
I really do love TikTok,
TikTok is such an amazing platform,
and I think it's definitely the future of social media.
I do know all the trends like,
I study TikTok a lot because of my job and
I felt like I had a really good grasp of it.
- Eva, I am so sorry I came for you.
- It's ok, it's ok. I should have done my research.
- No, you're good, I just--
- I felt like it's really hard to pinpoint
what a TikToker is and what a TikToker isn't,
because TikTok is filled with so many different kinds of people.
- It's a great platform to put out a positive message.
- It's like a big melting pot of different types of content.
- Just getting to do this on the zoom was really cool.
- Everyone was really nice.
- Overall, I had a really fun experience.
Thanks, Jubilee
- Bye!
- Congrats Angel!
(and other farewells)